so hello everyone thank you for coming
to my talk on measures and mismatches of
algorithmic fairness and so a quick
about me according to the Google cloud
vision API so I ran a picture of myself
through the Google cloud API of a vision
API this picture and I said multiple
things about me so let's go through some
of those dancer
oh yeah that's pretty true I'm an aerial
dancer in a circus acrobat
I just moonlight as a data scientist for
40 hours a week God pay that rent
somehow am i entertaining hopefully
you're stocking here with me for the
next 40 minutes
am i fun most of the time and what about
this one
am i girl so this is not true I am
assist man and I am also male presenting
I just realized that I was saying that
that could be interpreted in a different
way but the point of this example it's a
show example of bias and algorithms like
why did Google cloud vision think I am a
girl well that's because the data set I
was trained on when it looks at dancers
they're also primarily women so at
anytime and recognized it's like oh this
is an image of a dancer it also seems a
person in the image is a woman and this
is not just super glue Google cloud like
Microsoft computer vision API will
basically say the same thing I'll say
like oh this is a lady or I have had one
time one picture of me where it says
like oh this is an angel descending from
heaven which is technically wrong but in
spirit is actually right so what is
algorithmic fairness and I guess the
goal of algorithmic fairness is that is
this growing field of research that aims
to mitigate the effects of unwarranted
bias or discrimination on people and so
like this is more than just regular miss
classification okay if you have a image
recognition I like detect error that
tries to say if it's an animal as a cow
or horse like if you're miss recognizes
cows horses like yeah it's kind of bad
but no deep societal implications
because of that we really care about
like unwarranted effects of
discrimination on people and so you
might be adding stuff like well isn't
bison discrimination the like entire
basis of machine learning and this is a
kind of issue with this discussion
because bison discrimination is very
overloaded terms like
I say that a second overload term
compared to colonel and colonel being
the first one and like machine learning
data science where has like a bunch of
different meanings and algorithm various
that's primarily focused on like
creating mathematical formalism of
fairness like we're gonna take this math
mathematical definition I'm like this is
what fairness is as this equation and so
we're gonna come up solutions for that
mathematical equation and so this is
like problem I sort of have with like
the all this research it's like I think
it's really good I think it's great that
people are talking about these issues
but the issues solving mathematical
formulations is that you can solve the
mathematical formalism you have this
mathematical definition you can stop as
some constraint optimization problem but
does that actually do something for the
overarching societal like issue like if
you solve the math problem are you
solving the general problem that faces
society and I think it's important to
keep in mind that Ferris is inherently a
social and ethical concept and thing
about this is we only consider to be
fair changes with time
whereas mathema mathematical definitions
a sort of stay the same and I think one
thing to keep in mind is like so I guess
since this talk is really my criticism
not like this over books on like
mathematical formulae isms in
algorithmic fairness and I guess what do
I want to take away from this talk of
you like what I would say be the
underlying thesis so just sort of like
appropriate quote from my favorite mage
night I think the end goal of this talk
it should be that like in practice as
data scientists we should be using more
than just algorithms we need be thinking
about ethics I mean think about
anthropology well as we go about our
work we can't just like try to solve
this as like an algorithmic a computer
science problem like it
that's very text solution anything you'd
like oh we're just gonna use math and
suddenly hundreds or thousands of years
of racial and gender like segregation or
horrible effects will basically be
overdone just by this mathematical
algorithm like that's very tech solution
ISM and that's not how this works
and against a general idea of like this
research and fairness accountability
transparency machining this is the
interdisciplinary research area and
that's working to make machine learning
systems that work towards these goals
like traditionally machine learning
systems they serve just optimized
parameters they authorized accuracy they
authorized being a right getting the
right labels and they authorized these
like mathematical objectives but now we
sort of want to create machine learning
systems that currently work towards
or abstract goals just as fairness and
justice and as a result there's been
lots of research in this field like
there's lots of papers on this it was
actually the keynote at the conference
formerly known as nips last year and
it's become really popular like there'd
been classes on this now where it's like
maybe three four years ago it was just
like a very niche topic and we're even
having like a full like conference
dedicated to this kind of research
happening next January in Atlanta
Georgia is called the fat star
conference referencing like fare
scalability transparency machine
learning and also it's just not
researchers it's talking and caring
about this we're seeing algorithmic
fairness and the impacts of algorithm in
popular media and so we have like
several books such as weapons of mass
destruction automating quality
algorithms oppression
name a more iconic tree oh I'll wait
kind of thing talking about the effects
of like all of them is on different
types of people and I think it's
important because like we're now seeing
like what is the downstream effects of
our work on the everyday person like
when you're working at your job you sort
of just like work and making your models
meet your boss's requirements get your
paycheck go home where's now we're start
talking about like what's the downstream
effects of our models like yeah you're
not the immediately person kind of
immediate harm to use people but these
harms are being promoted or enhanced
because of your work and I think this is
important it's like no one really wants
to be the person who causes the
apocalypse no one wants to be the person
who causes the attack up like even if
you don't like consider yourself in
Ephesus and like oh I'm just a data
scientist it's not my job to like really
can I'll be concerned with like
downstream the effects of what I do I
just do my job I just do stats and I do
math and that's the what I do I think no
at the end like no one wants to be these
like the people being written about in
these books like that's just a terrible
career move but like oh hey I worked on
this project look hey isn't that like
terrible use of like computer algorithms
like no no that's not me and so even if
I can't convince you of like you should
care about algorithmic fairness if I'm
like a moral perspective like we should
just try to be good people maybe I can
convince you from like legal perspective
of oh hey we have these legal
regulations in the United States in
order to protect against disparate
impact against vulnerable populations so
this is protecting people and education
and employment based on race or gender
or religion
our place of origin things of that
nature and so like even I can't convince
you that you should care about fairness
from a moral perspective I can try to
convince you that you care about this
from you need to meet legal regulations
so you don't get fired and lose your job
perspective and especially now with GE
PR so this is global data protection
regulation this is the reason why you
see the bunch of emails and like April
May they're like we updated our terms
and services do you remember that and so
I think GPR is an interesting step
because like previously we just have
regulations for like specific fields
like credit or housing
whereas now GPR sort of like general
protections on like any use case of data
science or machine learning modeling of
like here the regulations you need to
meet and so that you prevent harm
against people and you also need to be
able to explain like what your models
are doing these people should be able to
understand like these algorithms are
like arbiters of your faith and
basically determines who gets alone who
doesn't and people don't understand how
they're making that decisions for them
and saying gee one cool aspect of gdpr
is sort of making interpreting your
requirement but you have to be able to
explain why your are really made a
decision into an end user so just talk
about types of algorithmic biases and so
it's like not just like all really
biases as like one giant vacuum there's
like ways you can sort of break it down
so the big problem we talk about it's
sort of a bias and allocation this is
really the most commonly research family
of all growth in fairness like this is
why we invented all those mathematical
definitions that I'm going to like talk
smack about later on
and basically the idea is like how do
your algorithms and models perform in
binary classification problems or like
multi classification problems just like
supervised learning across different
demographic groups so how does it
perform on men versus women how does it
perform on people based on race based on
religion and based on place of origin
things of that nature skin color and the
general idea is that like when we're
allocating these finite resources so
like who gets alone who doesn't who gets
a job who doesn't we serve off in favor
the privet costo for the more vulnerable
and that's just like years and centuries
of like systemic inequality being
aggregated into these data sets and so
when you train these models on these
bias or painted data sets the models
inherit those biases as well and so for
example there was a big story last month
where it Amazon has to scrape they're
like AI recruiting tool because it
showed bias against women and base
because of like the internal structure
of Amazon's company like okay they've
primarily had men if you analyze the
resumes of all the people who were in
Amazon sort of learn these factors that
secretly identify and use as being men
like having a name like Jared or like
say being a lacrosse player looking at I
guess hobbies as well and this is like
like I said this is why we have all the
math stuff this is what really are now
and like we were actually trying to
solve next problem is sort of bison
reputation this is like the harder
problem and this is like sort of where
the field is sort of going but we're
still struggling with this event and
start looking at how harmful labels or
representations are propagated so you
might have seen this picture before it's
like a very big story that well like
google photos was first released they
had this incident where they'll actually
label these uh group of black kids at a
graduation party as guerrillas and so
this is really really bad this isn't
just like oh you're all gonna made a Mis
classification this is make hey you made
a huge mess complication that like ties
into years of like racial bias and
basically ties into looks like this
racial slur against african-americans in
the United States and the issue of this
this is like it's often related to
ladies language in computer vision
problems these are like the neural
network problems look we don't
understand why is like what specific
thing about this made to say gorillas if
you using the neural networks are very
hard to interpret kind of thing and it's
really hard to quantify this error
compared to like biasing allocations
like looking at who gets the loan who
doesn't you can sort of like formally
measure the counts of like who got alone
who didn't whereas like it was a
representation like google photos is
really never going to say like a white
person as good as a gorilla kind of
thing like it's never gonna make that
mistake and bison reputation just goes
beyond like misclassifications like this
it's are concerned with promoting
harmful stereotypes our lack of
recognition so for example like snapchat
filters when you do these snapchat
filters they also brighten your skin and
this is because of like when you look at
like things like hot or not we sort of
believe like fair or lighter skin to be
more beautiful
therefore when these snapchat filters
are trying to make you more pretty for
social media they also brighten your
skin and so that's like it's doing the
optimization is meant to do properly but
we sort of inherently feel that
something wrong about this like this is
not right and this is not ideal we want
our algorithms propagating and the same
idea with language translation as well
so
this is translating from a
gender-neutral language of Malay into
English and we see that Swick pretty
much the same sentence structure but we
serve have these jobs being gendered
like he's a doctor he's a soldier he's a
professor these are sort of like male
jobs whereas she's a prostitute she's a
nurse and she's a maid these are little
female jobs we serve learn they'll okay
we have these jobs and we sort believe
that these are masculine jobs and these
are feminine jobs those also promoting
these like harmful stereotypes that we
don't want to promote and thinking about
this is interesting because I was doing
a run-through of this talk with a friend
she's like wonderings like this is
actually still happen and so I actually
did test this yesterday night and yeah
it actually still does like this
translation like this like if you
actually put in a sentence like he is a
prostitute translate to Malay and they
translate that back you get back she is
a prostitute
kind of thing and next is the
weaponization weaponization and machine
learning and so I think this is an
interesting thing like this is where we
need to be and so as data scientist
we're not really taught about how our
models could be used inappropriately and
so this is a big story last year with
some Stanford researchers basically
created a face recognition or face
detection algorithm that basically tries
to predict your sexual sexual
orientation based on your facial
features or a facial landmarks so I mean
in addition to like just promoting
shoddy science about like face
Lajja Nate this is called huge issue you
why because there are countries in the
world where homosexuality is punishable
by to death by the state like in these
like 10 or 11 countries if you're like
out of it as a homosexual you'll be
executed by the state so you can see if
this model was deployed and make you
public available someone can take this
and like out people as homosexuals in
these countries and that would put them
a huge danger and the thing about this
is like there's no mathematical
optimization or statistical method
that's gonna tell you that this is a bad
idea
like there's no mathematical formula
says like this is stupid you shouldn't
do this and this is what I feel like in
this discussion of like algorithmic
Ferris you can't really just look look
for tech solutions you need to bring in
emphasis you need to bring an
anthropologist and so I'm really glad I
was like as we're developing Lazydays
science and AI programs like Berkeley or
Carnegie Mellon or possibly at amu I got
you that we are including an ethics
compart
components to this because we really
need to think about like how could these
algorithms be misused by people who are
not us and like this is becoming a
Christian part because like AI is being
used in high-stakes situation now so
this is like a police using Amazon face
recognition in order to be like identify
criminals like okay we have this picture
of this criminal from like the security
footage can we just like take pictures
of people off the street and sort of
mash them together and that's how it's
being used but you don't realize that
like oh hey amazon face recognition well
it can't be long wrong and two is wrong
more often on certain groups of people
than other and so this is gonna be about
like the types of fairness measures so
we're talking about bias of allocation
how do you actually measure that bias
and so this is going to be based like
the mathematical notation I use here is
based off a paper cup called measures
and mish measures of fairness of which
is the inspiration for the title of this
talk and since but done out to
researchers at Stanford
Sam corporate Davies and shared Goyle
and so let's talk about definitions of
algorithmic fairness so there was like a
nice talk like earlier in February this
year by a Princeton professor Arvind uh
ordinary on about how there are 21
definitions of all graylek fairness and
I guess now there's more than like 30
definitions of algorithm fairness in the
literature how am i doing on time
perfect uh and then II think okay you
hear the story definitions there's gotta
be some definitions that are better than
the other right like it has to be this
like one better definition or this one
true definition of fairness and spoiler
alert there's not why cuz fairness and
itself is inherently this social and
like ethical concept it's this cultural
thing like what we define as fair
difference cross culture and so you
can't really narrow down like your
hundreds of years of centuries of like
ethical and social like pondering about
what should be truly fair how we should
orchestrate our societies it feels like
one quick mathematical definition how
are all these three definitions if we
can really break them down into like
three big families happy classification
classification parody and finally
calibration so let's talk about a few
classification and so this is sort of
the idea that okay when we have our data
set we have our features X we have some
protective features and we have some
unprotected features so protective
features are like you're protected
demographics these are your race these
are your sex these are your gender these
are your religious orient
easier place of origins heroes like
behind anti classification is that your
organs should ignore these features and
the thing we've learned recently as
we're doing this kind of work is that's
not just enough to like remove those
features from your training set you
can't just like drop those columns and
then feed that data through your model
and boom boom I'm dumb we're no longer
using race and gender we're safe now
what we've learned is that you can
accidentally learn proxy features and so
this is very famous story of staples
like the office supply supply company
they did a promotion of oh hey you live
within 20 feet of our competitors we're
gonna give you a huge special discount
in order to incentivize you to come to
our stores well the thing about that is
it sews based on location how they're
sort of like doing that who guesses who
gets this promotion or not is based on
where you live the thing is where you
live what neighborhood you live in
it's sort of tied into your
socioeconomic status their higher income
neighborhoods there are lower income
neighborhoods and as you might expect
there's different racial and
demographics of who lives in those
higher income neighborhoods versus who
live in those lower income neighborhoods
so by doing your classification or your
discrimination based on location you've
accidentally learned this proxy for race
and a result you get these you give
these promotions to people predominantly
white neighborhoods and Eritrea you
don't give any promotions to people
minority neighborhoods and that's sort
of basically acting the same as if you
were to discriminate against race and so
staples was hit with a huge lawsuit
because of this and so when we talk
about any classification now we also try
to prevent ourselves from learning these
proxy features and so this is a useful
framework for thinking about defining
like how we develop fairness aware
models and so what is a fairness aware
model so fairness aware models is sort
of like an extension of traditional
machine learning you have like decision
trees and we have neural networks and
they usually just take of features some
features X and when some labels Y but
now we have this set of protected
characteristics Z and what we want to do
is create a model that can predict our
label well but also doesn't accidentally
learn to predict the character risk
protected characteristics we don't want
to learn a subset of features they're
actually proxies for race or gender or
things of that nature and so like for
example this is a fairness of where
gam-gam being a general neural network
these are becoming very popular over the
last couple years basically they're
like AI art so like generating artwork
using AI they also from like real I
guess more formal like artworks until
all souls generating the anime style
artwork which I'm not I which I feel
should be referred to as gana may but
I've never seen anyone refer to it yes
yeah anyways so how this works like the
fairies to wear again is you basically
have two networks that sort compete with
each other one is the like traditional
classifier it basically has your data
and has the labels and I'm just trying
to like learn what features best predict
the label and then the adversary and I
think this is like a really brilliant
idea is that the adversary trying to
take the outputs of the classifier and
trying to predict the protected classes
so it's like I'm gonna take your results
and see how well I can predict these
protected classes because if I can take
your results and predate the classes
they protected classes like race or
gender or sex then you've accidentally
learned these proxies and so this is
what this optimization function does
this is a V like formal loss function
for it and so there's really two big
parts one is basically is this a good
classifier or not is this actually
learning through the labels properly
from the features and in the red box and
then in the blue box we have are you
accidentally learning those protected
attributes and so this is a trade-off
between like getting good loss of like
getting good accuracy on the labels but
penalize you for learning to protect
attributes it's looking you like stare
at this a bit and like look at it it
sort of reminds you of like
regularization so when you do like last
or regression or Ridge regression which
is like the stair tip I guess the
traditional way we talk about
regularization and machine learning
education it sort of looks like that
where's like you want to minimize the
loss function but we penalize you if
your model becomes too complex if your
model has like too high coefficients in
terms of like Ridge regression or lasso
regression it's sort of the same thing
here
like we want to learn a good classifier
but we want you to pay a penalty if you
accidentally learn these protected
attributes and so this is sometimes
referred to as the accuracy fairness
trade-off and I'm gonna be completely
honest I hate the fact this is referred
to as a trade-off because what we can't
expect the accuracy to drop if the test
set and their training set is biased
then we also expect the labels of the
test set to be a bias like we expect the
test set to have these societal biases
in them so we don't want to perfectly
emulate to test that we don't want to
get perfect accuracy on the test set
because we believe the test that is
wrong we believe the answer key is wrong
so
expect our accuracy balilla because you
want to deviate from this and I guess
also resign hate that's referred to as
like a trade off if he's like you know
like it plays into this idea that
somehow promoting diversity it's somehow
stopped optimal and so for example like
there's a company duolingo they're sort
of like a late an app that helps you
learn different languages these are now
set like oh hey we now have like 50% of
our software engineers are women and
that's like that's a really good thing
but then there's always like some more
all on Twitter it's like hey I got a
brilliant idea what if hiring people
instead of hiring people based on gender
why don't we hire the most talented
person for their job and it sort of ties
in this idea that like somehow by
promoting diversity is somehow hiring
less qualified or less optimal
candidates and that's not true at all
like promoting getting more diverse
opinions I think is really good for
machine learning and I'm really glad
that there are people like let's say
becoming a data scientist forum both of
you which is like who are working to
basically encourage like people from
non-traditional backgrounds to get a set
and interested in data science I think
is like having those voices in the rooms
is very useful because they sort of tell
you when you're being stupid hmm which
is very important yeah and now so what's
the big danger of like relying too
heavily on these anti classification
measures so by removing the protective
features we ignore the underlying
processes that affect these different
groups and so the season came back is
that Ferris is a process property like
we want people to be treated fairly when
we look at these fairness metrics and
this is like something I'll be harping
on as like you go through the rest of
talk is that these fairness metrics are
sort of focused on making the outcomes
equal and that's two different things
and so like there's like I guess we
talking like people say like oh skin
color doesn't matter we all be the same
but the counter-argument to that is like
yeah but we don't bleed for the same
reasons and I guess like that's the same
idea like yeah the outcome is the same
we all bleed the same but the process
uncovering it is different and so we
ignore that process you could
accidentally hurt people so for example
we talked about prison recidivism so
this is basically you have prisoners
inside
like what's the likelihood they're going
to reoffended some are they gonna commit
a crime again and get back in prison
because we if they do that we don't
really want to like release them right
now
and
we look at prison recidivism scores
basically you see is that like women and
men is our female male defense to keep
the terminology right is that women or
females and it's like if you have the
same score so this is basically risk or
say this is basically what's likelihood
we believe you're gonna fan as still in
some number between one and ten because
people understand what numbers between
110
I got a previously worked in
cybersecurity and I was taught like
never convey risk as like I try to just
convey risk as like 100 scale because
people understand that we understand 100
and spooky one is safe kind of thing and
so we say these are potential these
people to reoffending score and we see
is that for the same score
females I'll have a lower likelihood of
recidivism so that they are less likely
to reoffending ignore gender in this
case like you're trying to ignore gender
or ignore sex in this case and make
everything's equal then you would sort
of meet them in the middle like four
score seven we'd say these defendants
have a 50% chance of offending
reoffending and so the thing about that
is that like that increases the
likelihood of reoffending out and as a
result so females who would have been
released on parole these are at like
forty percent threshold will now be
detained at the 50% threshold because we
sort of ignore gender ignore sex and the
supposed to push their risk up and so by
ignoring this we sort of adversely
affect females and that's something we
don't want to do so next is
classification parity so classification
care classification parity is basically
the idea that we're okay we can't just
ignore like race and gender and other
protected characteristics we want to see
that our models do well across like
traditional measures so like accuracy
false positive rate false negative rate
is our measure like the same across
these different protected groups this is
what we usually use when we talk about
we would like do our all rhythm to
satisfy some legal legal regulation like
when our algorithms in those regulated
industries like banking or housing or I
guess like Equal Employment so like are
you like unfairly hiring too many people
of like white males for example like we
sort out of those algorithms or those
processes using like this type of
metrics and so here we have example of
some work by joy bull allow me
she's a PhD student at MIT and she does
this project called gender shades where
she shows that like these open like not
open source commercial face for
classification algorithms do really
poorly on darker skinned women or and so
like it does really great on lighter
skinned males and that's pretty good
really good on like lighter skinned
females and that's really good on like
darker skinned males but it's absolutely
like not absolutely terrible but like
significantly worse on darker skinned of
females and they show the largest gap
and so that's always just in this
example like pretty much the worst
versus the best like what is that gap
and this is sort of how this like
classification parody stuff looks at it
like what is the gap between these
metrics across different demographic
groups and so Joy's done a lot of work
on this she's actually done work the
show so I like face recognition
algorithms don't work on her because
until she wears like a white mask and
she also this really cool like spoken
word video called like AI ain't IA woman
I wish she shows like how these
commercial face recognition algorithms
actually don't detect like famous women
black women women in color so like
Michelle Obama Serena Williams are not
properly detected by these algorithms
also historical women like Sojourner
Truth also failed to be recognized by
these algorithms and so they're really
two big ways we think about like
classification parity the first one is
demographic parity and this basically
looks at the proportion of positive
outcomes by the protected group so if
we're talking about who gets a loan or
not it's basically is the likelihood of
you getting a loan based on your race or
your gender across equal across all
groups and that's essentially what this
mathematical form of the tops basically
says like I know math is kind of spooky
especially since I don't have like what
everything means but that's the general
idea that mathematical formulas trying
to convey and it's based off the the
stamp the two stanford research papers i
just took their notation and basically
this is what would be used to audit like
models for disparate impact we start
follow this 80% rule like is the
probability of getting a loan given that
you are man and the probability of
getting a loan given that you're a woman
are they within like 20% of each other
kind of thing like they have to be
within eighty percent of each other so
that means like are they off by most
like twenty percent and the key thing
that this sounds simple like okay do we
give loan
equal rates like are we overly favoring
one group over the other and thing about
this is you have to be careful because
this is like a media constraint and so
if you can satisfy this and just
satisfice immediately there's extra time
optimization like you satisfy them now
but they can have potential consequences
in the long run and so to show this
there are some group of researchers at
UC Berkeley and they have this paper
called delayed impact a fair machine
learning and when they showed for like
giving loans for example like you have a
the blue population whether it is the
minority population the orange which is
the like majority population and you
want the percentage of loans to be given
to both groups to be the same percentage
so like sixty percent of members of both
groups get the loan and think about you
don't think about like credit loans is
that like if you give lows to people who
can't pay them off their grand default
like they're gonna like lose money
because have to pay back all the
interest and then their credit score is
gonna go down so if you just want to
satisfy this um this constraint short
term like maybe we have to make the
number of loans we give between the
orange population the blue population
the same you might be giving too many
you like you might give lows the people
in the blue population who won't be able
to pay them back
and as a result they'll lose money
they're critical Rodo down and overall
the credit score distribution of the
blue population will go down so if you
just think about like satisfying the
immediate thing without thinking about
like long term you can eventually hurt
that population in the wrong loan like
you can cause their credit scores to go
down in the long run just because you
satisfy that median need of like we need
to give about X many loans in order to
satisfy this restraint and you see this
is like also in higher int that going
back to example hiring of like oh hey we
need to get underrepresented groups into
our company and you sort of just meet
that hiring process thing but if you
can't retain those people for like six
months or a year because of something
wrong with your company or your
environment where's the cost o to
underrepresented groups like should you
really get a pat on the back for that
like yeah you're able to get people in
but you're not able to keep them in and
we're not thinking about the long term
of like how do you evaluate whether our
company is good like diversity inclusion
wise so next is parody of false positive
rates this is sometimes called equal
opportunity and as the name suggests
we're sort of looking at the false
positive race across different groups so
this is going back to like the gender
shades thing we want to see that our all
of them is doing really well across all
groups and basically like we said it's a
basic
didn't have to say it has we wanna make
sure there are other error rate sort of
the same across all groups like we don't
want be significantly worse on black
women for example and face recognition
first then we are compared to white man
and the thing about this false positive
rate is that's possible to increase the
font like improve the false positive
rate by increasing the number of true
negatives so for example if you think
about false positive rate is if you're
number of false positives divided by the
false positives plus true negative rate
so if you want to get that number down
because I say you have like too many
false positives for a underrepresented
group well I have to do is increase the
two negatives so could that mean so
let's say for prison recidivism so what
is a false positives case this would be
detaining someone who an otherwise not
go on to commit a crime or not re offend
a true negative is releasing someone who
does not go on to Rhea fend you are like
the chief of police one police officer
or chief of police and sometimes the oh
hey your practices or sort of have like
too high false positive rates or your
algorithm has too high false positives
on a black man for example like you
basically detained to me black man who
would otherwise go on to not reoffending
to get this false positive write down
what can you do
you can crease that true negative rate
so what that mean is decrease the number
of black men who are released and they
go on don't go on commit another crime
so will that mean go arrest more black
men for like misdemeanors and low-impact
crimes like go possession for drug
possession of marijuana total out we've
made it fair now right no absolutely not
and so you don't really think about the
like how this data is generated or the
social process is generating that data
you can actually extremely harm that
vulnerable populations and the thing
about this is it's like this is widely
used and this has this huge oversight
that oh hey just nothing creased number
of true negatives and so calibration so
calibration is like the last major
family of like these fairness of metrics
and so in risk assessment so for example
like recidivism rates and also child
protective services there's some true
risks of the individual like if you
child stays in this household there's
some risk that the child will be harmed
and we won't sort of estimate that true
risk using some mathematical function s
and basic saying when this function is
Bob our threshold we're gonna intervene
or not so for example
Child Protective Services assigns
score two children this is a score going
from 1 to 20 why mean the child is
pretty safe in our household 20 means
the child is like in serious danger like
there's this is a super high risk
environment and CPS intervenes at this
like risk to the child is high enough so
a calibration you calculate this score s
and ya idea is that like once you have
this score s the outcome should be the
same so if you have two children who
have the same like risk score there the
likelihood of CPS intervening should be
same for both groups so that means if
you have child with a risk score of 10
or a risk or 15 to children one black
one white for example because it's a
huge issue where CPS intervenes more on
black households and they do on white
households that the f2 children how to
score 15 then the likelihood that CPS
intervenes should be the same on both it
should be like 75% for example for both
households so what is wrong with
statistical calibration so you know some
like the previous slides I usually just
had like a point at the bottom saying
danger here's what's the problem with
this is if I don't have this here
because I got a tire you slide just
dedicated what's the problem with
calibration so the problem of
calibration how am i doing okay I got to
speed this up a bit okay debate about
some calibration so this compass this is
the prison recidivism algorithm so this
is the longer than the term is like who
released on parole or not and so
basically science is score two prisoners
between one and ten and so 2016 Pro
Publica came that compass basically it
was black defiance they have a higher
false positive rate they are detaining
more black it with black defendants
they're sort of detained more often than
they should be who would otherwise go on
to not commit a crime if they were
released and North points like no our
risk scores are well calibrated by
groups and that basically means that
look okay if two people have the same
risk score so if you have these two
individuals and if they were to get the
same risk or they would both be detained
if it was above
they're both we would detain if they
both had the same high like risk score
the thing is if the underlying
distribution of the risk course is not
the same like if this we say like the
risk scores if it's above 8 or above
we're gonna tame and whites rarely ever
get risk scores of 8 or above but blacks
to get risk scores of 8 or above like
half the time ok yeah it's equal you're
attaining when they're above eight but
the underlying distribution is not the
same and therefore you're gonna tame
more black men than you or do white men
and so that's the issue with statistical
calibration like yeah you treat everyone
same but you don't acknowledge that the
underlying distribution is different for
these two groups and I think this really
goes to show that like you can optimize
for one of these like metrics and
horribly failed on these other metrics
and that's like a big result we're sort
of learning now there's a bunch of
papers about this this is what this
paper I'm basing this talk on it was
about like oh hey you really can't meet
all these Ferriss metrics like an ideal
world we can have like all the measures
of faster satisfied but you can't do
that there's sort of like incompatible
one another so I'm talking about like
one of these Ferriss metrics and so lot
of problems with them so what can we do
to better improve like algorithmic
fairness well stick a low-tech solution
or not low-tech but low staff low math
solution and then how we're going to
solve this problem with better
documentation that thing you claim you
should do that everything things you
should do but no one asked to actually
do and so this is like really cool idea
two really cool ideas so first it's
called data sheets for datasets and this
is done by Tim net gabru while she was
at Microsoft's fake group fairness
accountability transparency and ethics
and machine learning and basically takes
inspiration from Stanley's safety
standards and regulations and other
industries so like automobile to
automobile testing or clinical drug
trials where we use our real asset with
automobiles testing we Pro like they
basically test it on pro typically like
male-bodied dummies and so these crash
tests would pass these like these past
crash tests on these male dummies but in
here you see that logo Hey women and
children were horribly impacted by
actual crashes because a didn't actually
test for them and same thing with blood
drug trials where we realize okay we're
primarily testing on male participants
and so we don't actually understand the
side effects on women or other groups as
well and so a thing I love about this
data sheets for data sets it's like
they're long talked about models and
like you've read about medium post about
like different models and different
algorithms all the time but no one's
really talking about like what makes a
good training set like we just do them
like there's some data you grab the data
from kaggle or wherever you get your
data from and it's gonna be fun but no
one talks about like what makes a good
training set for a problem and I think
this is really like a first step and
discussion like what makes a good
training set because like the training
sets like the heart of this like if you
have terrible data sets if you have
terrible ingredients you're gonna make a
terrible dish no matter how good of a
chef you are you're treating to a
terrible training data you're gonna have
a terrible model no matter how good of a
data scientist you are
and so this documentation really sources
standardized like the types of things we
measure about we'd record about data
center like why was the data collected
who fun is creation does it contain any
like important sensitive information
like PII how was a dataset pre-processed
and also if the data relates to people
were they informed about how this data
is gonna be used because like informed
consent is an important part of like any
like research trial for social
scientists
yes somehow as computer scientist when
we do these a/b tests we sort of get
around this idea but getting informed
consent are on individuals and so that's
our real like about this it's sort of
standardize this and like this is like
for example as they get material safety
data sheet so it's like the chemistry
when chemists have like different
chemicals this sounds like all the
properties the chemicals like when is it
when it's it's chemical information and
also where some hazards and if you like
things go wrong how do you take care of
yourself first aid and so like comment
with the same thing for this four days
um data set to be useful like this is
data set this is where should be useful
and this is what you should not use it
for on at all and the model cards are
sort of like this analogous thing but
for machine learning models like trained
productionize models like let's have
better documentation about how we think
about machine learning models and so
this was Google researchers and so this
is when Tim net left Microsoft and
joined Google's research group they
basically proposed a similar thing of
like documentation standards for machine
learning models and so this includes
things like intended use like how should
this data model be used in practice how
should it not be used how was it
evaluate aggressive different
demographic groups and this is taking
the ideas of like oh hey automobiles
were not over tested on like male
dummies but not on female dummies well
we need to think about that for our
machine learning models like was it
tested on different groups based by
gender age race or skin type actually
learn while is doing this talk that
there's actually a formal classification
of different skin color so that was
really cool an also ethical concerns so
this is like if this model was like
doing it was supposed to do couldn't be
misused by someone and so this is tying
into like that sexuality classifier or
like I was also thinking about like when
I was doing my about me slide like how
could like face recognition
how does affect trans individuals like
could you accidentally out someone by
using face recognition technology and
then also other caveats as well and I
guess finally I'm gonna do some quick
shout out to some organizations I think
are really cool and so as a quick no I
from New York City and so like these are
song like New York centric things and so
if there are like equivalent
organizations in like the MV da area
please let me know after this talk so
first it's a I now Institute so this is
a Research Institute out of NYU and it
focuses on the societal and cultural
impacts of AI so this is like now not
try and think about like fairness and
machine learning and like protecting
groups totally from that like tech
solution or like math and algorithms but
then also bringing in like the F
emphasis or the anthropologist when we
talk about like how does AI affect
society and how they affect people and
they recently hosted a symposium on
their anno symposium on ethics
organizing and countability where they
talk about things I'm like the history
of scandals of like tech scandals this
year which is mostly just Facebook and
camera analytical and a lot of the
downstream things from that like last
year was uber dis to your Facebook who's
gonna be next year I'm excited to find
out mmm
hope it's Amazon sure I'm said that and
so I think it's like really cool like
way to have conversations about like AI
not just from a math math perspective
but like the social perspective like
winning face the recognition goes right
how could this be used because like face
recognition is like someone takes a
picture of you off the street without
your knowledge and boom is flash through
this classification algorithm this
recognition algorithm and they can get a
lot of information about you that you
don't want people to get about you so we
need to think about that we need like as
we further use face recognition
technology and like all parts of like
society the next one is the data for
good exchange and so this is a free
annual conference every September and
like Bloomberg's like New York City
headquarters that brings together like
data scientists non-government
organization leaders so this is like
nonprofits and also policymakers and so
if there's anything like this at in this
area especially in DC because I imagine
there are hope there is like some
conference where you bring together like
data scientists with policymakers
hopefully yes I think it's a really good
way to have like a combination like a
theoretical research and then also like
the best practices learned by
policymakers whereas like the
researchers i beyo say like oh hey you
should implement this the policymaker
says we try to implement this research
here's what actually happen in practice
compared to like your theoretical
results or you stimulated results in
your paper I think it's a really good
way to get more people into the room
just because like having different
viewpoints when we talk about the
effects of a eye on people is important
and
finally I just have like all the papers
I was sort of bringing up during this
talk so like the message of mismeasured
fairness delayed impact the fair machine
learning the data other data sheets
model cards gender shades that I talked
about throughout this talk and so it's
here in the like last slide I also this
is a paper that just came out pretty
recently called ferrous abstractions and
socio technical systems and this is sort
of like the same spirit of this talk of
like oh hey there's a lot of work and
it's all girls like fairness stuff but
they think the volunteers lobbies like
six common traps and they saw they
discuss like what are those traps and
this includes like the overs focus on
formalism and so that's the end of my
top talk and I hope you really enjoyed
it
[Applause]